Another equation that we will very often use, is Amdahl's
law, which we need to use when we're about speed
up on a part of the program, only some instructions,
and so on. So, basically when we have a speed
up, but it doesn't apply to the entire program, and
we want to know what is the overall speedup on
the entire program. So the overall speed up could be
computed, as 1 over 1 minus the fraction of the program
we didn't enhance. So for example, if we
speed up 40% of the program, then this would
be 60%, plus the fraction of the program
we did enhance. In this case the 40%, divided
by the speed up we achieved on that
enhancement, how did we get there? So the speedup
in this case is the improvement in performance,
which is 1 over the new execution time relative
to the old. So this is the part that we didn't improve, just stays
there. The part that we did improve, is shorter by the amount of improvement on
that part. It's very, very, very important to understand
that the fraction enhanced here, is a percentage of the original
execution time, that is affected by our enhancemen. Okay?
So it needs to be that 40%, of the time spent on the program. Is affected by our
speed up, not for example, 40% of the instructions
in the program, or something else other than the time.